26 years old the native of venezuela
making
his 12th start of the year
next offering swing and a miss struck
him out
swinging in a miss struck him out and
rosario is gone
and jose ramirez is back in the lineup
switch hitter
that's hit hard flag down on the grass
sogar gets up throws it out an absolute
rocket
off the back of ramirez
now it's going to be aaron savage on the
mound for the
indians
swings at the first pitch in a routine
ground out
one away
a little topper up the middle and an
easy double play ball for cesar
hernandez
elsa starts his wind up here it comes
swing and a high fly ball deep left
field back goes peterson track wall gone
that's how you break an o for 14.
you hit an opposite field home run into
the wind and into the left field
bleachers
and of course it's an indians home run
so the fan chucks it almost
hitting the second base umpire in
shallow center
and bobby bradley with his fifth home
run
and a great sign when he starts going
opposite field again
leading off for chicago anthony rizzo
swinging a miss threw it by him first
strikeout for savali one down here in
the second
three and one now
and the right he fires
and that ball's drilled out towards left
center cutting across is ramirez will
play it on a bounce contraire is racing
for second and wilson dives in with a
double
gets a 3-1 pitch he can handle
crushes the ball to the left-center gap
they're shading them just a little off
the right center and right out of the
box
he's sniffing double he's busting it
sliding in safely to second base
coaster contrast first extra base hit in
nine games
well here is patrick wisdom here's the
one too
swung on and missed not enough knowledge
bring up jack peterson top of the order
runner goes 3-2 swinging to miss throw
down it's in time and they got him
strike him out throw him out ends the
inning
three complete from the north side of
chicago
so now here's rizzo
in the air left field
rosario started back now in oh boy and
bias forgot how many outs
and it's a double play
hobby lost track of the outs
and ran all the way to third and it ends
up being a double play ross
took him aside in the dugout
he forgot how many outs there were
wasn't running real hard
by his reacting because
alcantara is the new shortstop took him
out of the game ramirez bounced to
second his first time up advert outline
delivers and there's a roller toward the
middle
corral by the shortstop throw to first
low drop by rizzo safe at first base is
ramirez and that will be a base hit for
harold ramirez how about that first play
with baez out who's a tremendous
defensive shortstop and alcantara
is unable to handle
that ground ball up the middle josh
naylor sent one to deep left field his
first time up
bradley's off
hit high in the air deep right field
gone to souvenir city josh naylor with a
two-run homer and it's three to nothing
cleveland
and just like the game owls ally pitched
against the tribe in cleveland he's
given up a solo homer and a two-run shot
well i'll tell you that was a pretty
swing by josh naylor right there he went
down and got that ball
what a nice swing two run homer the
indians now lead at three nothing
thompson
into the game
breaking ball lined to center coming off
nice catch by chris
[Applause]
and the 2-2 is inside full count
shaking that ham i don't know what
happened there hopefully he's not
dealing with a blister issue oh oh my
gosh this is even worse because this
doesn't look like a blister
well he's gone he's out of here
i don't know what it is that finger
or what
but at that last pitch you can see look
down at it
it'll be rosario ramirez and rosario
and that one hit to center bryant
a couple of steps back now in into his
left
line caught at first rizzo makes the
play
the o2
swaying and a miss pitch in the dirt
contreras puts the tag on rosario and
that is the inning
raphael ortega a left-handed batter is
going to pinch it for the cubs
rip to right base hit and ortega with a
pinch hit now
jack peterson over two
the 2-2 swing gonna miss he went up the
ladder and chased one
and peterson strikes out one away
chris bryant has walked twice
got him
bobby bradley makes the play inning over
brad wick 10th appearance
the o2
and a miss and wick
gets ramirez one away
tough to hit lefty on lefty matchup and
bust off that breaking ball right there
i mean just carved him up right there
well done
mr wick
three up three down and nick wikren
will take over
that's drilled to center and that's a
base hit
fifth straight inning they've had the
lead-off guy on base
hayward's goal is to keep the inning
alive
on the ground and that one sports
through
rizzo around second on his way to third
hayward into second it's a double
and they're in business second and third
and this is a very big at-bat
for eric sogart
he struck him out on ball four and the
cubs leave two stranded in scoring
position six consecutive strikeouts
between keegan thompson brad wick and
tommy nance
center field pretty well hit left center
it's going to one hop the fence
and into second base
with a two out double is cesar hernandez
his tenth
two bagger of the year
so the indians with another chance to
add on with two outs though
way outside and
look at that karim almost all the way to
third base this one was not even close
he did it again
are you kidding me exactly it was an
absolute instant replay
oh my goodness
[Applause]
i can't believe it this it was uh
identical
i mean to tell you you could show that
as a replay and no one would know the
difference james karen chick
will come on and try to close it out for
cleveland
book it
oh gets away long throws got him
a shutout to open the two gamer in
chicago
[Applause]